(upbeat enlightening music)
All right, we're back.
For those new or newer to the show,
Roll On is our inconsistently biweekly news
slash entertainment slash ask me anything mashup
where we loosen the metaphorical ties a bit,
discuss matters ranging from important to frivolous,
we answer listener questions, we have a few laughs,
hopefully a little bit of fun.
Adam, it has been eight weeks since our last Roll On.
And actually I think this is the longest that I've gone
without recording a podcast
in the history of the podcast itself
and certainly the longest gap
since we began our little thing here.
First, because of special holiday programming
like our annual Best Ofs,
and then because I've spent the last month,
the entirety of January, on sabbatical,
which we're gonna talk a little bit about today.
But the point is, today, we make a glorious return.
There's so much to cover and catch up on.
But first, how it goes at my long lost friend,
Mr. Adam Skolnick.
Rich, I don't wanna bore you
with the many inconveniences of modern life.
But are you familiar with the idea
that things shrink in cold water?
I have heard that rumor.
You have?
Yes.
You've heard it.
I lost my wedding band in my last swim.
You did.
In the Pacific Ocean,
or two swims ago, yeah.
You're not a real swimmer,
and certainly not a real open water or ocean swimmer
if you haven't lost your wedding band.
Is that right?
Yeah, in the vastness of our open seas.
You know what, it's funny.
I was talking to Goggins, like, later that day,
I think it was, and he said
that almost all Navy SEALs who were married
lost their wedding band in the ocean.
And then the ones, when they get a new one,
they put it under their watch because it's guaranteed.
Oh wow, that's interesting.
But I didn't know it.
'Cause I've swam in cold water so many times
and it's never been a problem,
but it's been really cold here.
And I felt it, it was like one of those things,
I felt it slip off and then, like, it registered
a half second later and I popped up and I'm like,
and it was gone.
Did you dive down and try to find it?
Of course I did.
About 85 times, but it was, you know.
Yeah, man.
I told a story about that in "Finding Ultra"
when I was on my first honeymoon with my short-lived,
I don't what you call it, and lost my wedding band.
And that had a very symbolic--
Well, you know what?
Nature to it.
But since then I did, like, people may know,
like I wear a wedding band
and that's because I've lost like three
that I've had with Julie--
Is that right?
Until at some point I was just like, "Forget it."
Right, so it's no longer a symbol.
This one, to be perfectly transparent, was,
I've been married twice
and it was a wedding band I already had.
'Cause we decided, April and I decided to get married
on, like, a Saturday, and we got married on a Thursday,
and it was just like, "You either go
and get something of the thing or we, or you--
So you used your wedding band from your former marriage?
Listen, I didn't come here for your judgment.
(both laugh)
So my wife didn't mind.
Like, I came back and I felt really bad.
And my wife's like, my wife didn't mind,
and she's already conveniently made an appointment
to purchase new wedding bands.
Good.
I think you should have one
that's just between the two of you guys.
Until I lose them.
But no, yeah, don't, maybe don't overspend,
because you're really gonna lose it again
if you go out into the ocean.
'Cause things do shrink in cold-water.
Things shrink.
And I was aware of something shrinking something, obviously,
but I didn't know knuckles shrink.
But that's what I learned.
Well, it's good to be with you again.
I feel a little nervous today.
I'm out of practice.
Like, this literally is the longest I've gone
without doing a podcast and as long as I can remember.
That's crazy.
Yeah, I'm like, I have butterflies.
I got home last night like one o'clock in the morning
and just came right in here to do this today,
so right back in it.
But I'm feeling good, excited to share with you today.
I'm excited to be the guy that's here
on this breaking back in.
I think it's a Roll On format is a good one
to get the juices flowin'.
Yeah, because, let's face it, the stakes are really low.
(both laugh)
Right?
Well, I'm just not that challenging.
I don't have to impress you.
I don't have to win you over.
No.
You can be sick of Fantec.
If my eyes get glassy from being tired,
I know that you can take the reins
and run with it a little bit.
If your eyes get glassy, you know what I'll say?
What?
Your eyes look wonderful.
See, that's why you have the job.
(both laugh)
In this echo chamber that we've created here,
where you just say nice things to me
and we continue to do this.
But I will say, over the break, lots of people out there
itching and aching for some Skolnick.
Yes.
Especially we started this new thing called Rollback,
where, on YouTube, when we don't have a midweek
Roll On episode or any other kinda episode,
we've started sharing audio-only episodes
from way back in the archive
that have never been on YouTube before.
All right.
And we've done that twice.
We had one with Gabor Mate and,
what was the one that we just put up the other,
oh, Josh LaJaunie.
And in the comments section, people are like,
"This is great rollback.
But, like, what happened to Roll On?"
There's a lot of speculation
and conspiracy theorizing going on.
There was a conspiracy theory.
That our relationship has disintegrated,
that maybe we got into a fight or something like that.
How come there's not, I took a break.
Right.
I mean, there was one theory that Brogan murdered me,
or at least kidnapped me.
Is there like some Reddit thread?
If you go to deep Reddit, it's not Reddit,
it's like the deep Reddit--
Some kind of 4chan situation?
Yeah, it's like Reddit's 4chan.
(both laugh)
There's a thing.
A lot of speculation.
There's someone
in the basement.
Screengrabs.
There's evidence.
Pictures of people
seen in the wild.
Yeah, proof he's not dead.
That's what they said.
Proof he's not dead.
Oh, that's a metaphor
for kind of the way the world is spinning at the moment.
Yeah, it's a minefield out there, Rich.
It is.
Yeah.
I heard there's a culture war afoot.
I wouldn't know about it 'cause I'm in an echo chamber
within an echo chamber.
Yeah, well, during my sabbatical,
I opted out of paying attention to anything, but--
Did you?
I did hear a little bit about a few things,
which we're gonna talk about today.
But before we get into all of that,
a couple of announcements that I wanna make,
especially since I've been gone
for an extended period of time.
We did create a couple new social media accounts
for the podcast.
@richrollpodcast on Instagram and Twitter.
When I was gone, it just made it easier
for the team here, who did a great job in my absence.
Clearly, I'm not fundamental to this operation,
because these guys did a great job when I was gone.
You're a figurehead.
Where, under those accounts,
there'll be posts about the latest episodes.
So the onus isn't always on me
to constantly be sharing on social media
about the latest episodes.
So check those out, subscribe, it frees me up.
'Cause this, it turns out, this social media stuff
is kind of a full-time gig
if you don't check yourself a little bit.
Do you feel like you're gonna be pulling back
from your Instagram account in some ways?
I mean, do you feel like--
No, just releases a little bit of the pressure.
A lot of people have other people
manage their social media accounts.
I just don't feel comfortable with that.
But then it means that like,
"Oh shit, today there's a new episode up.
I gotta think of somethin' to say
and download these photos and put them up,"
and these stuff takes time.
So anyway, it just makes my life a little bit easier.
So subscribe to those things.
Second announcement.
You've heard me talk about Taco Vega
a couple times on the podcast.
It's my friend, Jared Simons's restaurant
here on Los Angeles.
All plant-based, Mexican.
He's an incredible chef.
He's also an amazing endurance athlete.
Has done tons of Ironmans and ultra runs, just a good dude.
And I was heartbroken last week when he announced
that they were gonna be closing their doors.
They just couldn't make it work.
But there was this outpouring of support on social media
and so many people kind of showed up
on the final days before closing the restaurant
that he was able to kind of keep the doors open.
And he's doing it on a day-to-day basis right now.
So we're recording this on Monday, this goes up on Thursday.
I don't know whether he'll still be serving up food,
hopefully he is.
And in the even that he is
and you find yourself in Los Angeles,
make a point of stopping by at Taco Vega.
It's on Fairfax, near Canter's.
Pretty easy to find.
You can Google it.
And you can find Taco Vega on Instagram
and Jared Simons as well.
Give him some love, support.
I shared a little bit on my stories about that
and hopefully we can keep it open.
And if not, I'm sure he'll find some new thing soon.
But we gotta support our plant-based restaurants.
100%.
I tried to order, but out of delivery range.
Well, drive into town.
I'm going there.
I'm gonna drive into town.
Make sure you do it.
I will.
Another announcement I wanted to make
has to do with charity: water.
Some of you might remember back in, I think it was in 2017.
Well, I've had Scott Harrison on,
the founder of charity: water, couple times on the podcast.
Incredible guy, who's just reimagined
philanthropy pillar to post,
has created this amazing philanthropic effort
with charity: water to solve the global water crisis,
particularly in the developing world.
And I raised money for charity: water
for my birthday in 2017.
And I think we raised 80 grand through that campaign,
which was fantastic.
And charity: water started this thing called The Spring,
where you can donate monthly some amount
that gets just kind of autodebited from your account.
And I created a page to do that.
For us here at the podcast, we donate monthly.
And back at that time,
I was sort of sharing that with everybody,
but I kinda forgot about it 'cause it's sort of a said it
and forget it kinda thing.
And I decided to check back in
and see kind of where we were at
in terms of how much money we've raised
and I was shocked to discover that,
collectively, this Rich Roll podcast tribe
has raised $471,000--
Wow.
For charity: water,
which is unbelievable.
That's unbelievable.
I had no idea.
Apparently, we're the fourth highest donor
in this kind of Spring ecosystem under charity: water.
We've funded 13 water projects, 15,244 people had been aided
as a result of all of your collective effort.
So I'm just blown away by that
and I just wanted to say thank you to everybody
who has contributed, who heard about it through the podcast.
This is an incredible testament to the power of community
and the good nature of so many people.
And all of that occurred without me saying
as much as boo for like four or five years
'cause I literally haven't talked about this,
which means that actually we can seriously grow this impact.
So please if you're so inclined,
if you wanna learn more or you wanna get involved,
contribute whatever monthly amount,
you can do that by going to charitywater.org/richroll.
Unbelievable.
And that 15,244 people you've aided
is not a temporary thing.
I mean, you're aiding them for.
And that's generational.
Generations to come.
So 13 water projects, which means basically wells
in 13 villages where those communities
are getting served permanently, which is unbelievable.
Is that Africa, India type stuff?
I think it's mostly Africa.
I think on the website you could find out exactly
where all of those 13 are.
But anyway, shoutout to Scott as well.
It's super cool.
Meal Planner update.
There's been a significant increase
in both new sign ups and retention, which is awesome.
We get so many emails and testimonials
from people whose lives had been improved, benefited
in a positive way by the Meal Planner,
so thank you for that.
And I just wanna let everybody know
who's considering signing up for it
or who is already on board
that we're gonna be adding even more recipes,
including some special ones that feature SriMu,
Julie's plant-based cheese for Valentine's Day
and for the Super Bowl, including a discount on SriMu,
so keep a lookout for that.
We're also gonna be offering more fleshed out holiday
and seasonal content in the upcoming year.
And the service just keeps getting better
and better and better.
I'm really proud of the team that has built this
and who manages it.
It's really a great product.
It's super affordable and it's just great.
So for more on that, where to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
Rich Roll, did you just say Super Bowl?
I did.
Super Bowl is not your thing.
You're not in the Super Bowl.
Who's playing in the Super Bowl this year?
The Rams, buddy.
I know, yeah.
The Rams and some other team.
I do know that.
The Rams against the other guys.
I flew over, when I was flying home last night,
we flew over SoFi Stadium.
And you know how, when you fly over the top,
there's like video playing on the top
like illuminates from the sky?
Oh, I did not know that.
It's pretty cool.
I've never been in SoFi.
I have not either.
It was a great finish to the game.
It was quite something.
Yeah, it was all going down
when I was on an airplane, but--
Shout out Cooper Kupp.
Shout out Aaron Donald.
It's quite a year, yeah.
But that's about all I have to say about football.
Do you have a Super Bowl menu?
Let's talk about triathlon, Adam.
That's something I know a little bit about.
Let's get into sports that matters.
Apparently you know a little bit about
because you wrote this New York Times article--
I did.
On the Norwegians.
Why do they swim, bike, run so fast?
That article did really well.
I mean, it had beautiful placement
in the printed New York Times.
So congrats on that.
Thanks, man.
It was great to do.
It's further evidence of the Rich Roll podcast effect
on the New York Times sports coverage,
because I got the idea based on our very last Roll On
where you kinda had seeded it.
And Kristian Blummenfelt,
who I interviewed for a previous story on Ironman,
kinda how they were moving through you,
I got connected to Christian.
And then he basically blew the record out of the water,
the fastest known Ironman time by six plus minutes,
breaking Jan Frodeno's record.
What was his time?
Like 7:21 or something like that?
Yeah, 7:24.
7:24.
No, yeah, no, it's like in the story.
Is that wrong?
No, 7:21, I think.
You're right.
Yeah, I think it was 7:21.
Anyway, so I called Talbot Cox to kinda find out,
"What's the story behind all this and how do they do it?"
Originally, my pitch was kinda more like,
"I'd heard they did some data stuff.
I heard," and I was just gonna profile Kristian.
And then the more I got into the story,
I realized that it was basically this moneyball
comes to multisport.
Right, 'cause it's not,
I mean, Kristian is the tip of the spear,
but there's Gustav Eden, Iden,
I don't really say his last name,
and then there's another guy--
Casper.
Right.
So there's a whole thing going on in Norway.
Yes, and Casper's one.
He's beaten both those guys in different events.
And Gustav is, was an Olympian
and is the world champion at the half Ironman distance.
And then you got a Kristian who is the Olympic champion
in the Olympic distance, and now has
the fastest known time.
Crushing Ironman.
They don't call it a record
because the Cozumel course is complicated
and it's not certified.
Originally, it was called the world record,
but then they pulled back,
Professional Triathlete Organization pulled back,
but that was the first time
he's ever even done the distance.
He'd never done distance ever before.
He'd never done an Ironman before.
His first time out.
Ever.
So anyway, the story is about how is that possible,
how did that happen?
It's a really interesting, cool story
about these three young guys from Bergen and--
Who've known each other, like, their whole lives.
Since they were kids.
They all went to a sports kinda focused high school,
kinda like we've had the fame high schools here, that thing.
In Europe, there's sports schools that are kinda like that,
aimed towards Olympic-type sports.
He was a swimmer that couldn't win swimming races.
He was competitive, but he wasn't winning the races.
And so his swim coach basically said,
he saw him run one day and ran so well and said,
"You should try triathlon."
He went to a track local sprint triathlon and won the thing
as a high school student, he was 15.
And he got a call basically saying, "Hey, we're starting a,"
some parent, had a kid, who wanted to get into triathlons
and the parent, the father didn't know much about the sport,
but he just decided to form a local team,
and Kristian was one of the guys
and these other two guys also were from Bergen
and they showed up in this team.
So just crazy local talent.
But the story itself is really about how the data works
and what they do differently.
And long story short, serial entrepreneur,
from kind of a tech world named Olav Aleksander Bu
basically decided to shadow the Norwegian team
to Rio in 2016, to see if,
"Hey, maybe I could help with this sport.
Maybe I could,
I know the Norwegians have some good young athletes,
maybe I can help them in some way."
And basically realize that aside from Dan Lorang,
who's a great coach in his own right,
and is coach of Jan Frodeno and Lucy Charles-Barclay,
two of the greats,
aside from him and what he's done with data,
no one's even looking at data properly.
Even the coaches that are looking at VO2
or looking at lactate, they're not looking at them together
and they're not looking at it properly
or properly understanding it.
So he saw this huge gap
in the knowledge of what's happening to these athletes.
And these athletes, they're constantly on a clock,
they're constantly being monitored by their own gadgets,
they're constantly eating,
there's so much data just there that no one's harvesting.
So he kind of, it's about Kristian's greatness
and about Olav and Kristian working together
to harvest as much data as possible
and all the funny quirks about that.
So there's the inevitable kind of moneyball analogy
of like crunching these numbers
and coming up with better strategies
for training and racing.
I mean, one of the kind of practical takeaways
was that Kristian was riding too hard, right?
He was suffering on the run.
And so they figured out exactly how to dial back
his bike leg to a very precise degree,
such that his run would benefit tremendously as a result,
like that would be a specific example.
100%.
So they were using, they use CORE heating sensors
in a way that no one has.
And they use specific sensors
where they have proprietary interests,
because Olav got with different tech companies
that are working on this stuff and said,
"Hey, let us be your resource,
so you can beta test anything you want through us."
And so in that, part of that deal
is this stuff's proprietary.
So they have CORE heating sensors
'cause the skin heat, that's not your real core heat.
And if you've got the core heat,
you can really find out how close you are to red lining.
And so if you pull back just enough,
you can maintain that proper temperature.
Because basically the idea is only, even the best cyclists,
only about 20 to 25% of the calories they take in
goes to work, that goes towards work itself.
The rest of it just gets burned off as excess heat.
So if you're too hot, if your core temperature is too hot,
a lot of the calories you're taking in
all that just goes to heat, just gets burned away.
You mean in order to cool,
it's going towards cooling yourself.
Right.
Is that what you mean?
It gets burned off as, it heats you up actually.
I see.
Yeah.
So it doesn't go towards cooling yourself.
It doesn't do anything productive at all.
It just is more, you're feeding a fire
that is burning too hot.
Right, yeah.
The core temperature thing is such a big deal.
And it's a big reason why so many elite Ironman athletes
have had trouble when it comes to Kona,
because they can dominate in these other races,
and then they get to Kona and the heat and the wind
and all this sort of stuff
and they start running into stomach issues
and overheating issues
that they haven't had to contend with,
and they don't have appropriate fueling strategies for those
because it's so different than these other places.
And so even among the best athletes,
the most elite out there, they've had struggles.
I mean, Chris McCormack went through this,
it took him years to like figure out
how to solve that equation so that he could win that race.
And he's just one of many examples of that.
So I think that's super interesting.
In addition to that, I know that Kristian also wears a CGM,
a constant glucose monitor, is that what it stands for?
Yeah.
Supersapiens.
So they add that like blood glucose detection
into that mix as well.
And then there's this kind of clickbaity thing
about the $2,000 water.
Yes.
What is that about?
So it's a $2,000 water
that's infused with particular isotope
so that when he pees,
they can put it into a mass spectrometer
and find out how well he's metabolizing oxygen.
And then he, they also burn fecal samples
to find out how well he's metabolizing his carbohydrates.
What's funny, it was very cheeky,
like Kristian, sometime last week,
or when did the article came out?
Like 10 days ago or something like that?
Yeah, something like that, two weeks ago, yeah.
When it came out, he shared on Instagram stories
him drinking the $2,000 water,
which I thought was very funny.
But I think it's important to note,
like all this is really interesting,
this is at the very cutting edge of science
and sport performance, and we're talking about
the most elite athletes in the sport.
And I think it's important to contextualize that
against the rest of us who are the huffer/duffers
and the average people.
Lindsay Crouse, former podcast guest, New York Times writer,
did you see the piece that she just wrote?
I did see that, yeah.
About ditching her data.
Like, basically the other,
that's the other end of the spectrum.
Like, I'm done with my watch.
Like, I just wanna go out and enjoy running
in kind of a purest way.
So both of these have their logic.
Like, what is your goal?
Right, yeah, I agree with you.
And just real quick.
If you wanna take a Layman's view,
and if you are interested in getting faster or,
in a scientific way, essentially,
basically what people were doing was
the American side of the sport was looking at VO2 max,
which is kind of your max potential.
And you could hit your max performance,
but maybe only hold it for 30 minutes
or an hour or something like that.
Lactate meters, from what Dan Lorang told me,
was more a European thing.
They were checking out the lactate tolerance in the blood
and that enabled you to go long,
but it wasn't really focused on max performance;
it was more focused on maximum endurance.
And so what Dan did
was mix those two understandings together
to try to expand your max fitness
and hold it for a longer period of time.
And what Olav Aleksander Bu is doing is
is basically taking that and jumping five steps ahead
using more monitors to better understand it.
And Dan says,
"If there's ever a sensor I can't use, he's happy."
So Dan is, and he's coached arguably the great,
certainly the greatest of his generation,
three-time Ironman champion Jan Frodeno,
who's been able to win races deep into his 30s.
I think he's 40 now or something.
So he cares about data.
And Dan and Olav are friends,
and they talk about this stuff a lot.
So I don't know.
I mean, if you're looking at it
from kind of a Layman's perspective,
there's definitely something there
in terms of trying to maximize your best performance rate
and then expand that ability to stay there for a long time.
'Cause we have VO2 max here,
but that doesn't really dictate how fast you go.
I've never paid attention to that ever.
Well, it's not a real one anyway, yes.
But setting my zones based on lactate levels
has always been super important to me.
I talk endlessly about zone two.
But understanding what your zone two is,
which is where you develop your aerobic base
and your aerobic capacity,
you have to be properly lactate-tested
to establish those zones.
And the more aerobically fit you are,
the flatter that curve is
in terms of like the lactate increase
as you escalate your effort and your intensity
and the quicker you kind of go back to baseline.
And in endurance sports, like VO2 max,
I've always thought of it as being not that important
because you're not, what your threshold is
isn't really crucial;
it's how vast your aerobic capacity is.
Like, your ability to maintain
like a subthreshold effort
for the longest period of time possible and recovery quickly
so that when you ramp it up into a tempo effort,
you can then go quickly back down to baseline.
And so what they're trying to do is basically make that--
Work both sides of that.
Yeah, and make that max something they can hold
for a period of time.
But anyway, back to your thing, just to wrap it up.
Kristian won in Tokyo, where the heat was,
obviously it's very well documented
how hot the Olympics were in July in Tokyo.
And he won,
passing runners that were supposed to be faster than him
because he had dialed it back just enough on the bike
and then he just, they were wilting.
And he won the race by 11 seconds.
And the thing that's not in this story that he told me
is he called his shot.
When he was a teenager, when he was 17,
he was interviewed by a local paper in Bergen,
and he guaranteed an Olympic win.
Guaranteed it.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, and then he did it.
Wow.
With this data as part of it.
But he's not like a boisterous,
like he's a very soft-spoken, like, sweet guy.
Yes.
But they're hardcore, man, these guys.
Like, they wanna win bad.
And so it'll be interesting to see what happens
in St. George.
I'm hoping to be there.
And the funniest part about that story was,
when I talked to Olav, he's so smart.
Like, the first time I talked to him for like two hours
and I left the phone, and I'm like,
"I don't even know what,"
like, "I shouldn't do this story.
I'm not smart enough."
And then I talked to him for like four hours
over three different times over a period of time
before I fully kinda wrap my head,
"How do I make this simple?
How do I make it engaging,"
because it's all so engaging.
How do you kinda pair it down?
And so that's what it took for me.
And it's pretty funny, like how much you have to,
'cause usually I just drop into a world
and I'm able to figure it out enough
and get enough good stuff pretty quickly to turn it around,
I like over researching those.
So I'm always erring on that side.
But with this, it was a real challenge for me
to get to that point of confidence--
Because it was so scientist.
So in the weeds--
And it's so different from what I do.
I mean, my inner core is like Lindsey Crouse,
like I didn't have a smartwatch
'till, like, I got a dive watch that happens--
You don't even have goggles.
(both laugh)
You have smart goggles.
Yeah, I do.
I do, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't have dumb goggles.
That's cool.
No, so everyone check it out.
We'll link it up in the show notes,
along with a couple other articles about these Norwegians.
Did you talk, before we close this out,
did you talk at all about this Sub7 project?
I did.
I talked to them about it.
We didn't include it
because that's something for next summer.
And so the idea behind the Sub7 project,
I think we've talked about it on here before.
I think we have, yeah.
Yeah, just that it's Kristian against,
why am I spacing on the other guy's name?
Gustav?
No, it's not Gustav.
It's an English athlete.
Oh, one of the Brownlees?
Yeah, Brownlee, Alistair Brownlee.
They're going head up against each other
and they're trying to do it,
it's like the Kipchoge two-hour model.
And so they're allowed to use
certain number of support crew.
I think they're allowed to have a Peloton on the bike.
It's gonna be a very flat course.
It's all gonna be--
They haven't announced the course yet
or the dates.
No, no, no.
So we don't know where this is gonna happen.
Did they tell you and you can't say or--
No, no, no.
Nothing's been announced yet.
But yeah, I think it was 7:21 and change was his time.
So he has to find 20 more minutes.
But if you read the story, you'll see.
Kristian was suffering from stomach problems
that whole week before Cozumel and--
He had a virus or somethin'.
But I talked to the guy who owns the Cozumel Ironman,
and he owns the company that puts it on,
and he said that everyone was raving about Kristian,
how mellow he was.
He showed up there at like midnight
at the airport by himself, no entourage, no nothing,
not fussy at all.
He was like embraced and beloved by the people
who put on the race, so that's cool.
Yeah, cool.
Yeah.
Good.
Well, keep us posted.
I will.
All right, let's take a quick break
and we'll be back with thoughts
on the whole Joe Rogan Spotify situation,
some thoughts on my sabbatical, what I took away from that,
a couple other cool things,
some listener questions, and more.
So we'll be right back.
(thrilling music)
So, Adam, I don't know if you know this,
but the culture war is afoot.
It is alive and well.
Are we really gonna step into this?
Very, very gingerly.
There's no winners.
Nobody wins in this space.
By talking about this.
No, no, nobody wins in this space.
But it is what's happening right now,
and I guess I feel like it's on a lot of people's minds.
And I know that people have reached out to me,
they'd like me to offer some thoughts about this,
which I have some trepidation around
because I'm not one for advice.
If there's one thing that I've learned,
and I learned this in recovery early and often,
I'm reluctant to give advice.
I'm somebody who likes to share
from a perspective of experience.
So I try to steer clear of treading in waters
where I'm not an expert.
So we're gonna talk about this perhaps briefly
and as kind of gently as we can.
But I think, as many people know,
there's this controversy that's occurred
over the last several days
where Joe Rogan is sort of in the midst of a crossfire
over particularly recent podcast episodes
with McCullough and Malone
these, I don't know how you would characterize them,
doctors with non-mainstream opinions about vaccination.
And the result of these conversations
have caused certain artists out there
to decide to pull their music from Spotify,
which has put Spotify in this position of needing to
or feeling like they have to respond to this.
And Spotify, as of yesterday,
had published a blog post by Daniel Ek, their CEO,
wherein he kind of disclosed publicly for the first time
these content guidelines and how they're going to,
I guess, label certain conversations from time to time
that are potentially in that misinformation space.
And so, of course, this has caused quite the outbreak
of opinionated puppet masters out there.
What is your take on this?
Well, I mean, not just opinions,
but like Spotify's stock went down 6% at one point.
Yeah, I think they lost $4 billion in market share,
and there's other factors.
I don't think you can just point
to the Joe Rogan controversy
and say this is all because of that.
No, I think it was Barry Manilow getting involved.
Is that what--
Yeah, 'cause first it was Neil Young, then Barry Manilow.
But then Barry Manilow tweeted the other day like,
"I don't know what people are talking about.
I haven't said anything about this."
Oh, I'm sorry that was some misinformation on my part.
There's misinformation right there.
Barry Manilow fake news.
He was brought into this somehow.
Yeah, I know.
So you have to take all of this with a little bit
of a grain of salt.
Right.
Well, my theory on all of this stuff is,
first, there's only one kind of free speech.
And so either in favor of free speech,
whether that's free speech moderated by companies
or free speech moderated by governments, or you're not
and you wanna control speech in some way.
And I'm in favor of free speech, and may the best ideas win.
And secondly, I don't think Joe Rogan traffics
intentionally in misinformation.
So that's the other thing.
He might have opinions that differ from people,
he might be a libertarian,
remember, he was pro Bernie Sanders also at one point,
so he's got very interesting viewpoints,
but he's not, we're not comparing him to Fox News anchors
that are intentionally muddying the waters
and causing disinformation.
I hold him in a completely different space,
and I don't go to him for medical advice.
So those are my ultimate opinions on that.
And I think that in this culture war,
we are trapped between the righteous and the ignorant.
Those are the two loud viewpoints that we have.
We have the righteous, the self-righteous,
and we have the malevolent, malevolent,
the malevolence of ignorance on the other.
And it's not that fun to be in that space,
because it's loud and it's disorienting
and most of us are not there.
Most of us are somewhere in the middle.
We can handle differing opinions.
We can figure out what to believe.
And the funny part about being, between those two poles,
is that on social media we all toggle between them.
We can all be righteous
and we can all be a little bit ignorant.
And so when we do that,
when we make the people who have dissenting opinions,
we try to, when we try to snuff them out,
we make them heroes, we make them the anti-establishment,
we make them the punk rockers.
We turn people like Matt Gaetz,
who is the most punchable face in America, into a hero
for all sorts of young people out there
that are looking at the mainstream culture and thinking,
"No," and that it's dangerous.
That's why the Balinese have this culture,
cultural idea of you can't crush the darkness.
There's light and there's darkness,
and you can't try to obliterate it.
That's the point of free speech.
You can't try to knock it out entirely.
It's impossible.
That's why you have to cherish speech
and let everybody talk,
because then that only helps you figure out
the best way to go forward.
I know it's a challenging time,
but that's really the only way.
Because when you ridicule people
like Aaron Rodgers and Kyrie Irving
and these people who have these,
like you said, non-mainstream opinions about vaccines,
you make them heroes, you actually elevate them.
And that's the problem.
The Streisand effect.
Yeah.
How do you feel about Spotify's declarations
around content moderation, and labeling, and the like?
I mean, they're sort of taking a page
out of the Facebook playbook like,
"Are you just a distribution platform
or are you a publisher,"
and that's a very difficult situation to be in.
It's almost an impossible situation for Spotify.
I don't see them like kicking Rogan off the platform.
I don't think that's gonna happen,
nor do I think that they should do that.
So they kind of issued this
somewhat toothless response about,
"Well, we're gonna do a better job
of putting labels on things from time to time,
or pulling things that clearly violate
our relatively vague policy."
Right.
Well, I like the label because then I could just say,
"Oh, he's gonna talk about COVID-19, I won't tune in."
(both laugh)
I feel like I'm getting enough COVID information.
I don't need to actively seek out more.
That's what's so weird, is, like,
there's a lot of people making a living
off of screaming and yelling about COVID.
Well, sure.
And the incentives are set up
such that, particularly on Twitter,
there's no incentive to be nuanced
and balanced about anything.
You're rewarded for outrage on both sides of this spectrum.
So with the exception of the occasional super long thread,
like it's the hot take that basically travels
and that's what we're trafficking in.
But I think it is important to point out,
as you astutely noted a moment ago,
that most people are not in this space.
Like, we're kind of in the middle,
we're trying to figure out what's true and what's not.
And give us a little bit credit
when it comes to discernment, right?
Over the course of my sabbatical,
I did spend a fair amount of time
trying to make sense for myself of this world
that feels at times like it's losing its grip on reality,
depending upon what your information bubble looks like.
So on the subject of the sort of polar extremes
on the one hand, are, we could hold the perspective,
are people and institutions flawed and sometimes mistaken?
Does science make mistakes
or does science, from time to time,
change their mind when new information comes in?
Does the scientific,
does the consensus scientific community screw up
and at times air egregiously
when it comes to messaging the populous?
Are the incentives of the media misaligned?
Do we have serious problems in government, tech, media,
and at times science?
Like, I would agree that all of those things are true.
Or is there a secret psyops event
of untold proportions afoot
where this cabal of organized evil is organizing
to control our minds and our bodies?
Yes.
Is that true also?
I mean, no way, that's not true.
Maybe part of that is true, I don't know.
Probably not.
But this idea that either, like, we should just
give Anthony Fauci a crown and name all our pets Fauci
and just put him on our t-shirts and lay down at his feet,
or there's a crazy conspiracy afoot of mind control.
Right.
Are people naming their dogs Fauci,
'cause that is a dog name.
Yeah, that's a thing.
That's a thing?
For sure.
A lot of people are doing that.
Okay.
I didn't realize he was worth it.
So listen, live in the gray
and I live in the nuance and I defer to that former idea,
which is that there are scientists who are working hard
to solve a very difficult problem,
and they're doing it anonymously and imperfectly,
and the messaging isn't always great,
and there's been lots of flubs,
and there's reason to distrust the media.
And I don't wanna spend a lot of time on this.
I don't wanna go down some crazy vaccine rabbit hole.
I really don't wanna dwell on this very long.
I am, like I said at the outset,
reluctant to even bring it up
because it is so unbelievably divisive
and because whatever I say
is unlikely to change anyone's mind.
But I do feel that it is important to say
that although there have been mistakes
and there's been overreach, I'm not in favor of mandates
and I think that there's been a lot of errors made
in terms of kids in schools and what's going on there,
and I understand the problems of Big Pharma
and the misaligned incentives there,
but I do, like I said, believe that there are good people,
good scientists who are trying to solve
difficult problems imperfectly.
And as for the Rogan kind of Spotify situation specifically,
I'm not into deep platforming,
I don't think that's a solution.
I don't think that he should be punted off Spotify.
And I think this goes back to this issue of incentives.
There are incentives to host heterodox thinkers
and there are incentives to be heterodox in your thinking.
And I think heterodoxy is very appealing to many right now,
especially with this degraded trust
in media and institutions
and even more so when that heterodox thinking
entails a conspiracy.
There's something about our neurochemistry that lights up,
suddenly the world makes sense.
And when you combine that with this media distrust,
it creates an interesting
and, at times, problematic scenario.
But the truth is just because you are heterodox
does not mean that you are correct.
Maybe you are correct about one thing,
but perhaps you were wrong about a thousand other things.
And I think generally the heterodox idea is not correct.
Consensus scientists are not out doing podcasts.
And many of these heterodox secular guru types,
if you look at them, if you kind of canvas these people
and try to identify similarities
or common themes among them,
a lot of them seem to have a past
where they had been dismissed or ignored
or maligned by institutions,
particularly academic institutions,
and as such their anti-establishment perspectives
then become fueled by resentment
and jealousy and pettiness.
So it's this misunderstood genius problem, right?
Like, I figured this out, nobody is seeing me,
and there's like an irritation there
that is driving this need to be seen and to be heard
and to become like this secular guru on the internet.
Right, and then you take that,
that's a great backstory for like misunderstood genius X,
which is like, it's so true.
And then you take that and what you get is
people who are skeptical,
but they're only skeptical in one way, right?
I'm skeptical of mainstream media
or I'm skeptical of Big Pharma.
Then they hear someone like that,
but they don't bring that same skepticism
for this random person.
Right.
No, the skepticism is very specifically directed.
And you know my theory on that is?
As long as that misunderstood genius
aligns with that worldview,
then suddenly there's a myopia
when it comes to that skepticism
being applied to that person.
If COVID-19 has revealed anything,
specifically to the United States of America,
it's that we are intensely self-interested,
and I would say only self-interested.
And these cultural wars do the same thing.
They focus every, through this lens,
I'm gonna tell myself a story.
And I had very good friends
that had their four-month-old in the hospital for a week
in the last, right before all this kinda talk broke out,
and it was very touch-and-go,
COVID positive, also about RSV,
so fighting two of these crazy viruses at four-months-old
on oxygen for three days in intensive care.
Baby's fine now.
It's all gonna be good.
But I know the stakes.
I have a 17-month-old at home.
I'm very careful.
I don't live, we don't live normal life still.
Even though a lot of people are getting comfortable
with the way things are, I'm still very careful,
we're still very careful.
And so I know the stakes.
But the thing is, is like the people in my position
with children under five and can't be vaccinated,
we see things and we think people should act
in a way that would suit our particular situation.
People in your position that have older kids,
that are dealing with kids
that have to be in mask at school,
or maybe my sister's kids are a little bit older than mine,
they're seeing the same kind of thing.
They're like, "How can I make this work,
that's not going to impact my child's early education,
my child's language acquisition,"
which is some of the problems with mask at schools.
And so we all see these things, we have to remind ourselves,
we're seeing it through our lens
and nobody else is seeing it through our lens.
And you have your little subgroup,
but that doesn't make your subgroup correct,
that other people should be acting a certain way.
But we lose track of that, right?
And you can put any issue on the table,
I guarantee, it's not that different.
It's like we're so self-interested.
We're so obsessed with what's affecting us,
that a mask is a big problem, or this is a big problem.
And then you look at other countries that 95% are in line
with whatever the public health information
they're getting tells them,
and that tells me that they care more
about public a little bit more
because maybe they don't agree with all of that,
but they're willing to do it
because that's what they are told the community needs.
And so I'm not making any judgments on anybody.
I'm just kinda reminding us all
that we are all just self-interested A-holes at heart.
Well, there's something very, very American about that.
And this idea of rugged individualism
and it's all about liberty.
But liberty has to be calibrated against responsibility.
Those liberties require a certain level of responsibility.
And what is our responsibility
to the collective whole, right?
And so sometimes we gotta do things that we don't wanna do
for the betterment of everyone.
But I think that breaks down
with this loss of trust in the media,
when we feel like we're not getting the full truth
or the whole truth or we're being misguided.
And I think that that distrust has eroded to the point
where it's perhaps irreparable for certain people
and it creates this receptivity to other ideas
or a sense of transparency and honesty from other people
where the message is coming to them in an unfiltered way.
And there's a lack of skepticism is one word,
but also just critical thinking around
the information that we're receiving.
And so I think it,
again, like I'm not into deplatforming anyone
and, like, I think that gets,
that's a little too close to banning books,
which is also the other thing that's going on right now.
It's happened.
This is happening in tandem.
And the people that, it's interesting that the people
that wanna ban these certain books from schools
are probably, by and large, like pro Joe Rogan
and the people that wanna deplatform Rogan
are railing against the banning of the books.
You can't have these things both ways.
Yeah.
And one book in particular that was more recent was "Maus,"
which is like a Seminole graphic novel
about what Jews went through during the Holocaust.
And it's amazing book and I highly recommend it.
And it just displays it a couple ways because you,
I don't think the people
that are banning "Maus" in Tennessee,
in that one school district, actually listen to Joe Rogan,
to be honest with you.
They're just a bunch of, like,
there obviously is a white nationalist problem
in that county.
There's no other way to interpret that.
And they're not the only people who are saying,
comparing what's happening now to the Holocaust.
So that's happening at the same time.
So right-wing people are banning the "Maus,"
and at the same time people on the right are comparing the,
what unvaccinated people in this country are going through
to the Jews in the Holocaust.
And it's extremely irresponsible and very offensive
for me, personally, to hear that.
And it's absolutely absurd.
But I would never ban them from being able to say that.
You know what I mean?
I'm, like, the ACLU, old ACLU.
Old, yeah, not the current ACLU,
which just seems to have lost its sort of, like, footing
with right all of this.
I'm the old ACLU that says,
"Let the idiot Nazis speak, because there's such morons
no one will ever--
Ira Glass,
wasn't the guy's name that used to run that?
Ira Glass?
I think that's his name, yeah.
Is it really?
Mm-hmm.
The other Ira Glass.
Anyway, but you hit the nail on the head.
Like, the "Maus" book is being banned,
and everyone's like, "That's impossible," but you're right.
Plenty of people on the left are looking at Joe Rogan
and saying, "Well, he should be held responsible."
It's like, "You can't have it both ways.
There's only one way."
But you can also make the argument, can you not,
that Neil Young is saying,
"I don't want my music on Spotify,"
is his exercise of speech.
There's a subtext to that
because it's coupled with his sort of demand,
"Either take Rogan off the pod,
off of Spotify or I'll do this."
So it's speech coupled with that interest,
so there is a deplatforming energy behind that.
Definitely.
Which makes it a little bit more than just speech,
but it is an exercise of speech nonetheless.
It is.
I mean, he's allowed to do that.
Obviously he's, come on, everyone loves Neil Young.
I have so much respect for Neil Young
and his music's incredible
and he's always been very political.
And I support anyone's, they can try to do it,
but then you don't tell me in the very next day,
when you release a second statement,
that you're always pro-free speech,
cause you're actually not.
You are not.
You're pro a certain political point of view,
which is you're right, that's fine,
and you're using your incredibly powerful music
to get a point across, and it's had a huge impact.
But I don't believe that that is a
objectively old ACLU free speech take.
I don't think he probably is in that camp.
Meanwhile, Brene Brown announced that she would not,
who has an exclusive deal with Spotify,
I think she has two podcasts there,
is not gonna be releasing any new episodes,
which is a, that's a bold move on her part.
Very bold.
It's very interesting to see it happen.
And I'm so, like, I've become,
I was very political in the early and mid '90s,
like I was an activist during a time
when everyone was making a ton of money
and nobody really cared about these thorny issues,
and I was dedicating my life to it, making no money.
And so it's funny to be in this position now
where everyone is intensely political.
It makes me wanna not be,
it makes me wanna be completely apolitical.
That's how I think about these
intensely political people right now.
I'm actually getting a view of what I sound like.
Like being the Nirvana fan from day one
and then deciding you're no longer a Nirvana fan
when they left sub pop or what, you know.
Yeah, something like that.
Right, exactly.
I'm like, I'm looking at it now,
I'm like, "God, did I sound like that to people
for five years," 'cause that's what, you know.
You're surrounded by people from different sides
and most people are uninformed.
That's the bottom line.
Yeah.
So again--
Uninformed.
I just think, again,
like, deplatforming is not the answer here.
Censorship is not the answer here.
It's taking responsibility
for having a more robust information diet.
And shouldering the responsibility to be a critical thinker
with respect to everything that's coming in,
not just the stuff you disagree with,
but the stuff that tends to light you up inside anyway,
like rings those dopamine bells.
And so I thought it would be helpful,
especially for those that might feel the tug
or the pull or the seduction of some of these secular gurus
who are spinning heterodox thought out there
to offer a couple content pieces
that might expand your silo.
And one that I found very helpful
and enjoyable at the same time, entertaining
is a podcast called Decoding the Gurus.
These guys are great.
These two guys, Chris Kavanagh and Matt Browne.
Chris is from Belfast,
and Matt, I think he lives in Melbourne,
he's Australian, an anthropologist and a psychologist
who basically deconstruct podcast episodes
with some of these secular gurus,
particularly the well-known members of the IDW.
And they really do a great job
of separating the wheat from the chaff
and helping you to understand how to separate
or kind of discern what's factual, what's baseless,
how to tell the difference and--
IDW, meaning internet--
Intellectual dark web.
Yeah, yeah.
And kind of distinguishing between good and bad science.
And they do it in a very entertaining way.
They have a great dynamic.
I mean, nothing like you and me.
No, I mean, come on.
I mean, they're pretenders to the crown
when it comes to that.
If you want some good talking head content, come to us.
But the accents are great
and they have a lot of fun doing it.
And I found it to be enjoyable to listen to these guys
in terms of, like, I hate this word,
but, like, sense-making, right?
Like, how do we make sense?
Like, what is true and what isn't?
And we all need a little bit of help
and we need to step outside of our comfort zones
and hear from other people.
We can't just take what we hear for granted.
Let's also entertain some critical thought
around those ideas.
Another suggestion would be Rebel Wisdom.
This guy David Fuller, who's a former BBC journalist,
who I would deem, basically,
somebody who's doing responsible heterodoxy,
who kind of looks at the heterodox space,
tries to understand what's good heterodox thought
and what isn't.
And he's got a YouTube channel,
makes lots of videos about this subject matter
and I find him to be fairly reliable
and smart and informative.
And then third would be,
and this is specific to kind of the vaccine space,
Peter Attia's the Drive Podcast,
where he's had a couple,
what I would characterize as very balanced,
responsible discussions on COVID and vaccines, including--
Early on, he was very much saying, "No, this is real.
COVID's very scary."
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, he's very pro-vaccine,
but also not afraid to be critical
where public health policy seems to disconnect from logic.
Like for example, if young children are in school,
they're all vaccinated, the teachers are vaccinated,
like, why are they all wearing masks?
Like, does this make sense?
Like, having kind of a grounded conversation
around the science.
And he's done some, I think, pretty responsible advocacy
around this in terms of what is true, what isn't true
when it comes to vaccines and vax safety.
A couple of recent podcasts where he had ZDogg on there,
Zubin, I forget his last name.
ZDogg?
Yeah, ZDogg.
That sounds like Peter likes,
Peter's proud of his physique too, I've noticed.
Well, Peter's an interesting guy.
He's very strong.
He is an ultra-endurance swimmer.
I'm pretty sure he's tight with Steve Munatones.
Really?
Well, Peter had,
I think he did a double Lanai to Maui crossing.
Peter did that.
Yeah, like a long time ago.
That's amazing.
And he's done some pretty interesting cycling stuff.
He's very fit.
I mean, he's a good athlete.
And pretty smart and just grounded in his approach
to all of this, so maybe check that out as well.
As for Spotify, again, they're in a tough spot.
It'll be interesting to see
how this story kind of unfolds over the coming weeks
'cause I think we're definitely not done with this.
No.
But we are.
No, maybe we're done talking about it.
I mean, this story is still unfolding is what I'm saying.
And by the time this podcast comes out on Thursday,
who knows where all of this will be.
Well, one final note on the book banning.
By the way, the author of "The Sympathizer,"
which is a great novel, kind of a,
this Vietnam war novel from a Vietnam,
Vietnamese person's perspective,
he's an American, Vietnamese heritage.
His name is Viet Thanh Nguyen.
He wrote a great piece about books and book banning
and all of that in the New York Times as an opinion piece.
He's a professor at USC, great novelist.
His novel won the National Book Award, I'm pretty sure.
And anyway, he had a great piece about,
and very much against any sort of deplatforming
and book banning type thing.
And one of the points he makes is anytime you ban a book,
look what happens.
And "Maus," which was banned in this one county,
in one school district in Tennessee,
was number four on Amazon when I went to buy it,
like, 'cause I'd given my copy away years ago.
I noticed that as well.
And so it's like,
that's the point we're trying to make, right?
Like, the deplatforming thing, if you really care,
it doesn't actually help,
like, if your problem is too many people are hearing this,
deplatforming won't solve that problem.
Well, particularly in Rogan's case.
I mean, biggest podcast in the world.
He could go anywhere and take his entire audience with him.
It's a nonissue.
Right.
Maybe he would be even better off or happier if podcast,
if Spotify found a way to release him from that contract
or let him go.
Maybe, who knows.
So it's not even really--
His podcast would still be huge, is the point, yeah.
Maybe even bigger.
It wouldn't suffer in the least.
It might even grow larger.
Right, right, right.
All right, let's move on.
I wanna talk about things I learned on my month off.
But before that, we have another little thing
that I wanna cover.
Another meta, another piece of the metaverse.
Yeah.
This also relates to, like, media and news,
and fake news and misinformation, I suppose.
You got served by the metaverse.
A little bit.
Yeah, the metaverse?
Yeah, isn't it?
The internet.
The internet, like, basically something about you
is picked up and examined
by, like, individuals on the internet.
And so it was like an internet thing
that was examined by the internet a hundred different ways.
Right.
So what happened was a couple weeks ago
I was a guest on Tim Ferriss's podcast,
and that was a big deal for me.
I mean, he's got this incredible podcast
and unbelievable audience.
It was quite an honor for me to be a guest on that show.
And I was, in all honesty and transparency,
like I was nervous.
And then even after we recorded it,
I was all up in my head about it.
I was like, "I don't think I,
I don't feel like I did a good job."
And I was like, "Oh, no one's gonna like this."
Really, you get that way?
Yeah.
I was totally up in my head about it.
'Cause that's how your guests feel when they leave here.
Now I have a lot more sympathy?
Yeah, that has been a thing recently
with a couple of guests.
And I'm always assuring them, like, that they were great.
And I literally, for like two weeks or whatever,
I was, "Ah, I blew that.
It was a great opportunity to like,"
but anyway, people seem to enjoy it.
I think it's doing well or did well.
And I got a lot of nice feedback and comments
from a lot of people.
And it was really, again, like an honor
to share parts of my story with his audience.
In that conversation, though, I told the tent story,
which I've told many times here.
I don't need to rehash it.
I sleep in a tent.
I have slept in a tent for a couple of years.
There's many reasons for that.
I explained the basics of that to Tim.
And that story ended up getting picked up by the media
while I was away, Insider,
which I think is a subsidiary of Business Insider
that covers kind of the creator economy, the internet,
published an article called
"A man who sleeps in a tent in his yard
while his wife sleeps in their bed."
While his wife sleeps fine in their bed.
Listen, it could've been worse,
but it was kind of a snarky clickbaity,
nonstory of an article.
But apparently a lot of people read that
'cause it was like trending on their site for a day or two.
And didn't they use like a piece of content
that you'd put up on your Instagram?
I had made a video like five years ago
or something like that, why I sleep in a tent.
It was a video I made forever ago.
I know.
And that was like--
And that resurfaced as a result of this
and now has gotten tons of views
over the last like week and a half or whatever
as a result of this.
But it was being picked up as if this was,
had just happened.
Nobody said like,
"Oh, here's a video he made five years ago."
It was like, "Oh, I just made this video yesterday."
But it's because I had been on Tim's show,
so that kinda put it into kind of a current lens.
And what was funny about that article was,
like, clearly the journalist
didn't really know anything about me,
didn't appear to even really Google me.
It was just a very kind of what you would expect
from sort of a hackneyed whatever piece.
And so I was like, I'm just ignoring this.
Like I said, it wasn't, if you read it,
it's not necessarily that bad.
At times it actually kind of defends me, like,
but it's sort of presented as if like this guy,
this guy, rich Malibu guy sleeps in his backyard and like,
while his wife's here, claims his marriage is fine,
but could that possibly be true?
It was like a story written by the clickbait journalists
from White Lotus.
It was that kind of--
In fact, I thought of that, yeah,
where Connie Britton dresses her down for her listicles
and calling herself a journalist.
It was like written by a listicle specialist.
Basically, that's exactly right.
So I was like, I'm ignoring this.
It'll go away.
This is not real.
And then the news cycle just continued to move along.
Like, it got picked up.
I guess, like, these articles get syndicated
so then they end up on all these other websites.
Yeah, the same one ended up on Yahoo.
They get translated, it was on Yahoo, MSN.
It just wouldn't go away.
They're reading about you in Burkina Faso.
Like on Twitter, there was a local radio DJ
who did five minutes on it, making fun of me,
like in some town, I don't even know where, you know.
I was like, "I can't believe this."
And then The Young Turks,
which is a big progressive news YouTube channel,
they have like five million subscribers,
well, there's, is it Cenk, Cenk?
How do you say his name, Cenk Uygur?
The main guy on The Young Turks.
But there's these other two pundits,
Ana Kasparian and John Iadarola,
who do a show there, I guess.
I guess.
And so they did a whole thing--
I watched that.
Made a video,
"Why is this husband sleeping alone in a tent,"
and did like 10 minutes on me
for this standalone video on The Young Turks.
There's like over a hundred thousand views
where they're just making fun of me and riffing about this--
John is kinda defending you.
But they didn't even, a little bit.
He did a little bit.
She was taking hits at me.
She was.
But neither of them, like,
just if you just Googled my name or just like,
"Oh, he has a podcast," or, "Oh, he wrote a book,"
or, "Oh, he did these--
Oh, he's bigger than we are.
No, it was just rich Malibu guy, like, blah, blah, blah.
And it just, it wasn't like,
again, I just decided to ignore this whole thing,
but I think the kinda takeaway--
It's bizarre, though.
It was weird.
And it was definitely, like, it could've gone worse.
And it is this weird feeling of vulnerability.
I mean, I did make that video, why I sleep in a tent,
so I put it out there and I told the story on Tim
and I've talked about it many times here,
so I'm not hiding anything.
Yeah, there was also that--
But there's like when you're at the prey
of some journalists in their hot take,
you feel a little bit powerless,
like, "Oh, they're gonna spin this story
and I feel defenseless here."
It is a weird feeling.
And it made me realize also like,
"Can't believe what you see or what you read
or what you," you know.
It's like, this is just, these people are just doing a job.
They need to fill this content.
Like, why are The Young Turks
even talking about this at all?
This is not about news or politics or anything like that.
Was it a slow news day?
It's just something that's entertaining for people.
Oh, here's something to, here's some junk fast food story
for you to chew on for five minutes.
Well, my biggest takeaway from The Young Turks thing
is it reminded me why I've never watched
or listened to The Young Turks.
Like, I'm not interested.
But also, there's a difference between journalism,
actual journalism, and what you've described here.
And the problem is now people look at that
and I think that's what they think journalism is.
And it is, unfortunately.
Like, you go on CNN and any major news network,
and it's mostly a bunch of talking heads
talking about stuff.
It's not really reporters on the ground doing the hard work.
And so then we look at The Young Turks
talking about this story as if that's a story,
like as if that's a news story
to be discussed by people and parsed.
And it's very lazy and bad content
and strange to go in and take someone's like sleep habits.
It's cool for you to talk about
because it's important to you.
But it's not cool for, like,
I think it's just bizarre that,
like, people take these nonstories
and make them into things just to fill our ears with sound.
Yeah.
So anyway, that was, it was,
I think basically, in the wake of the whole thing,
I should just, by the way,
like I've upgraded the tent since then.
So I got back last night,
like I got the glamping tent set up.
It's super dope.
I've got a bed.
It's amazing, right?
So I think I'm just gonna take some photos in the tent
or in front of the tent--
Enjoy the tent.
And just say, "Fuck you."
Yeah, I fucking sleep in the tent.
Yeah, here's my tent, asshole.
I also think that, I think of the Willie Nelson phrase,
where he said, he's told,
I once interviewed Jack Johnson
and Willie Nelson told him once,
"You don't read your press, you weigh it."
And that, like, in your case, it's like,
who cares what they're saying about you?
They're saying something about you
and that's all that matters.
Yeah, it's just weird.
It is weird.
I know.
Anyway, all right, let's move on.
I just spent a full month in Maui.
I flew there on January first, just got back last night.
Today's the 31st.
This is the third year that I've taken this sabbatical.
And so I thought it would be kind of instructive
to talk a little bit about like why I do this
and what I've learned.
And it was just a great experience.
I mean, it's the most chill and relaxed
and distant that I've been from work
in the three years that I've started doing this.
And I just feel so refreshed and renewed
from the experience.
Basically, it was an opportunity
to completely break ranks with work,
be off the computer, be off email,
not have anything to do with anything professional
and just exercise some self-care.
So I established like a daily routine.
I brought my bike, so I would ride every other day.
And on the days in between, I'd go to the gym,
and swim, and chill.
I just feel better than I have in quite a long time,
physically and mentally.
And I went to Maui, I was originally,
I wanted to go to Byron Bay in Australia again,
but just getting to Australia was too problematic
with COVID and all of that.
And Maui was the one Hawaiian island
that I knew the least about.
I've spent tons of time on the Big Island,
tons of time on Kauai.
I'd been to Maui before.
I did EPIC5 there and I've been there on one other occasion.
But I wanted to learn more about that island.
And now, in retrospect, it's like my favorite island.
Oh yeah?
It was so great.
All right.
First of all, it has the best cycling
of any island in Hawaii--
'Cause of the terrain's varied?
First of all, the pavement is great everywhere,
which is not the case on some of the other islands.
But there's a lot of terrain variability,
tons of coastal rides and climbs,
and a lot of really interesting routes,
upcountry, and inland.
And then, of course, you have the Haleakala Climb,
which I did last Thursday.
Did you?
Yeah, shout out to Jonathan Hostick
and his beautiful wife, Laura and their kids,
Marin and Isla.
So Jonathan was a guy who was out riding one day
and I was going up this climb and the guy rode down past me,
but he shouted my name out, I knew he recognized me,
and he whipped around, we rode a little bit together,
and he just said, "I'm here for a while.
I live in Toronto.
I'm just gonna be riding every day.
If you wanna ride, and I'm gonna do Haleakala
probably a couple of times,
so if you wanna do it, Laura will sag us, crew us."
Oh, cool.
So we have some support.
And I thought that would be cool.
So last Thursday we did it.
It's a 34-mile climb,
where you gain 10,000 feet of elevation.
Wow.
This is half assed internet research,
but I think it's the second longest climb in the world.
That's what Jonathan said.
We should probably fact check that.
But incredible, like, to climb to 10,000 feet.
And we had this epic day
where usually it's freezing up there
when you get to the top,
but it was like 63 degrees and totally pleasant
above the cloud line.
Just extraordinary.
But that was just one of like many epic rides.
So I really kind of fell back in love with riding
'cause I hadn't been cycling that much.
And because of my back,
I'm really taking a break from running at the moment,
but I can ride my bike without it being problematic.
So it was just fantastic to be on the bike,
in the warm weather,
and to really kind of just reset everything.
And I think--
Did you swim in the ocean?
Swim in the ocean.
There's also a great aquatic center in Kihei.
I was staying in Kihei.
Like, multiple eight-lane pools
and basically not that many people.
They're free.
You can just walk in and go.
So great swimming facility, ocean swimming, cycling--
Did you cycle to Hana?
Not all the way.
I was staying in Kihei,
which is not where the great cycling is.
So sometimes I would drive to Paia and then ride,
I rode like most of the way to Hana one day and rode back,
but didn't make it all the way there.
I drove upcountry one day and then road the road to Hana
on the other side, going the other way,
which is like you descend for like an hour and a half
and then you, it's like I better turn around.
But the grades are like 10 to 13% going back,
which is pretty steep.
So all the work is on the way back.
But I never made it all the way to Hana.
Okay.
You need to have like some simple--
Have you done that?
No, no, no.
I've been to Hana one time when I was a kid,
like a long time ago.
And like, not since I've really been a traveler, so yeah.
Yeah, I highly recommend it.
But part of it, of course,
is to have this analog experience, right,
and not be on the phone.
Right.
How'd you do?
But I didn't go, like, under the idea that I would not,
I was not bringing my phone with me
or anything like drastic like that.
I was like, "I am going to temper my phone use.
I'm gonna be a responsible iPhone user."
Did you have like a standard that you were going for,
like a certain number hours a day or something?
These guys here were running the business,
so I wasn't worried about
having to like be involved in that.
But I've got a kid who's applying to a school,
who was gonna need help on the application,
I'm talking to my family every day, we're FaceTiming,
there's things that have to get dealt with.
So the idea was like, "Look, I'll check my email,
like, maybe once every two days."
I have an autoresponder up,
and I'm just gonna limit my phone use as much as possible.
And I would say that
in terms of like where reality met aspiration,
I'd give myself like, I don't know, a B minus--
Is that because of Wordle?
Maybe a C plus.
Would you have gotten an A without Wordle?
Wordle was a problem.
(Adam laughs)
Wordle was indulgent, though.
Wordle's self-care, buddy.
Yeah, I'm not worried about Wordle.
It's all the other stuff.
Just (mumbles) Wordle on your Twitter, that's all.
And there were times where I found myself like,
"Why am I sitting here scrolling Twitter,"
like, "This is my opportunity to not do that."
And I have no excuse and no reason.
But that allure, that pull is so strong.
But then it becomes like this spiral of,
then you criticize yourself for doing it
and then you, like, beat yourself up.
(Adam laughs)
I'm an expert at that.
Wait, what am I doing?
I'm wasting my time.
It's hard, man.
It's hard.
And then you come up with these justifications
or these rationalizations
and then you're just in this like mental looping spiral
of like negative emotions.
And then you're like, "What am I doing?
I'm supposed to be off of this fucking thing."
Which is interesting because I have this book here
sitting on my counter "Stolen Focus" by Johann Hari,
who's coming in I think next week to talk about it.
So I'm about halfway through this book.
And this book is about this exact thing.
And part of it is it's not our fault.
Like, these things are so powerful
that we are powerless to basically rebut their wiles.
And it is really difficult.
And this book is great.
It's kind of about Johann's own version of this experience
and also the science behind how our focus is being eroded
as a result of technology and kind of our modern world.
And I look forward to talking to him.
I always love talking to him about it
when he comes onto the show,
but I was having my own like lived experience
with this problem that I think is relatable to everybody
who's ever tried to put the phone away.
But when you strip away all of the excuses,
like I have no work excuse,
I am here for the specific purpose
of kind of simplifying my life and getting clarity,
and to have it creep into that,
like, makes me realize just how pernicious it is
and how difficult it is to create healthy boundaries
around the phone.
So for the most part, I did fine,
but I had these like lapses that made me realize
like how powerless I can be at times
when it comes to this kind of stuff.
But in terms of what I learned,
like that's sort of the negative aspect of this.
I mean, for me,
like, it was great to not be on social media.
Like, I didn't post anything about being there.
I didn't really want anyone to know that I was there.
I really didn't wanna have any complexities.
I am a true introvert.
And I realized that I had no problem ostensibly
being entirely alone for this entire month
and barely talking to anybody.
Like, I was totally fine with that.
I needed that to kind of like heal
and restore my energy levels.
I also realized, and I've learned this in the past,
but this idea that, the way that our culture is set up,
you go on vacation for a week or maybe two weeks,
but I didn't even feel myself slowing down
until I was like in the third week.
Yes, it takes two weeks.
It takes two weeks.
It takes longer.
And I realized how privileged I am
and how special this opportunity was
that I was able to take advantage of.
But the idea that you're gonna go away for a couple days
and come back refreshed is ludicrous.
It takes two weeks to get into a new state of being.
And then if you come home right after it,
you never really explore that state of being.
So then you start to unwind in the third week.
The unwinding doesn't start until like day 15, 16.
Sure, yeah, yeah.
And it's not then until, it's not until then
that you even begin to get any clarity at all
on like how you're living your life.
100%.
So I have another thought on that that I wanna share.
Let me put a pin in that.
But I also, I learned that I like routine,
even when I don't need it.
Like, even when you're in a place
where it's like you don't need routine.
I was happier when I was like,
"Okay, my routine is I'm gonna ride my bike every other day
and I'm gonna go to gym gym on the other days."
But also, to say, "I'm not here on a training camp.
I don't have to be agenda-driven,"
but to have some kind of structure,
I don't know, for some reason made me feel better
about the experience than just being like,
"I'm just gonna like not have any schedule whatsoever."
So it's that balance of like having some kind of routine
while also not overscheduling things.
I learned that the world spins in my absence,
which is great for the control issues
and a healthy dose of humility that I'm not that important.
That was good.
I mentioned that, yes, I fell back in love with cycling.
I don't think that I could ever live on an island.
No?
By the time
the month came up, I was ready to come back.
What about the island?
So despite all the introverted tendencies that I have,
like, I really missed people and it was time to reconnect.
But I think to go back to that point that I put a pin in,
the biggest thing that, I think, I took away
that I've learned from this experience
is when you get to that, like when I'm in that third week
and I have put enough distance between me
and these kind of work patterns
to have some level of clarity,
I found myself confronting this default setting
that I have to always be like achieving, producing,
progressing, like even,
like, "Okay, I'm gonna ride my bike.
Well, I should ride harder or longer than I did last time,"
or like, "What am I trying to, what is my angle here,
how am I gonna make myself better
through the result of this?"
Like, wait a minute,
that's not what this experience is about.
You're not at a training camp.
You don't have to be agenda-driven.
Can you just be?
And that's the hardest part of all, right?
Like, can you just sit with yourself
and be in the allowing of experience
without it being connected to
or tied to some trajectory that's moving you
in a certain direction or in accordance--
No, no, I can't.
Yeah, it's like, and it was amazing to me,
like I would notice that,
and then I would really begin to appreciate
like how strong that impulse it was.
It's like, "Oh my God."
Every time I'm like, "Oh, I should,"
or even when I was like, "You know what,
I'm a little tired today,
like maybe I'll just hang out here and read.
No, you should drive to Hana.
No, you should, there's that one trail
you haven't checked out yet.
You better go check it out,
because I don't know if you're gonna have time to do it."
It's like all of that, right?
Like, it's all tied to how am I progressing,
how am I improving myself, what am I missing,
what is the thing that I'm gonna like beat myself up for
if I don't do it?
And realizing how ingrained that is, I think,
was the biggest kind of epiphany in the whole thing.
Yeah, I mean, I think that's pretty,
that kind of epiphany isn't,
yeah, I mean, that's the unwinding, right?
That's the whole idea.
That's why you did it, right?
That, I think, is why you did it, right?
And that's why you keep doing it
because that unwinding is so critical.
I remember, April and I did a delayed kinda extra honeymoon,
'cause we did this very quick ceremony and then we did,
we didn't celebrate it for a while
'cause of work commitments,
and then we went on a trip to Fiji, Tonga, and Australia.
And it was mostly a dive trip
and to reconnect with her homeland.
And then when we were first planning it,
like, she was planning it for like 10 weeks
or something like that
and I scaled it back to like six weeks.
And then about two weeks in, I turned to her and I'm like,
"Why did I tell us to come home?"
Like, once you're out, it's good to stay out.
Like, once you're unwound,
it doesn't matter how long you're gone.
'Cause like you said,
the world's always here when you get back.
I don't regret coming back early.
But like knowing that,
it's something I'll never forget next time
'cause it's like you can always be,
it could always be a little longer.
That's for sure.
Although I would say that I was ready to come back.
I was excited to get back.
I missed me some Skolnick.
Dude.
I miss the guys here.
I miss my family.
We need you here.
And now I'm enthusiastic to be back.
These guys were a mess without you.
I mean, they did their jobs.
These guys are just fine.
But there was a lot of sobbing.
Although Blake's walking around with a cane,
something about his back.
It is a cane or a trekking pole?
It's a trekking pole masquerading as a cane.
(both laugh)
It's an emotionally--
Something about a bad back from all those ultras.
I don't know.
He's chuckling back there.
All right, let's move on.
We're gonna share a couple pieces of content, right?
Yeah, yeah, we are.
Enjoying?
Yeah.
You wanna go first?
Well, I think, well, I was,
I think my content, I have here,
is keying off of the Alan Watts stuff
that you wanted to post.
Yeah, so I'll start.
I mean, the first thing that I wanted to draw attention to
is this catalog of talks by Alan Watts
that Sam Harris has made available on his Waking Up app.
And I spent a lot of time with Alan Watts
over the course of my sabbatical.
I think I got through maybe
somewhere between 30 and 40 hours of this.
There's 142 hours.
Wow.
Of Alan Watts talks on the Waking Up app.
For people that don't know, Alan was kind of,
he's kind of perceived as the guy who helped introduce
Eastern wisdom to the West.
He was a incredible speaker and writer,
who is influential on the counterculture
of the '50s and the '60s.
He wrote over 25 books--
Particularly Zen,
Buddhism, right?
Yeah, Zen, Buddhism, wrote a ton of books,
charismatic speaker.
And this catalog is like a gift.
Like, I can't believe that there's this one place
where you can go and you can listen to
as much Alan Watts as you could ever want to.
It starts to, 'cause it's broken into categories,
but these are talks that he's given over the years,
so certain stories repeat themselves and themes recur
and things like that.
But I found it to be just incredibly nourishing
and beautiful.
So that is one thing that I've definitely been enjoying.
That's cool.
I read one of his books when I was in my early stages,
trying to piece together my spiritual worldview.
But I found him so academic, like he's so smart,
like it was just very hard for me to fully engage him.
But I think it's
You should revisit.
I should.
Just because I know you wanted to talk about that,
I just wanted to quickly acknowledge
Thich Nhat Hanh's death,
a master Buddhist monk who was anti, the number one antiwar,
anti-Vietnam War peace activist from Vietnam.
In 1964, he started speaking out against the war
and ended up having to be exiled, relocated to France.
And over the period of time, he got Martin Luther King Jr.
to pay more attention to Vietnam War
and speak out against the Vietnam War.
Martin Luther King Jr. then nominated him
for the Nobel Peace Prize, written many books.
I have a book in my library, "Old Path White Clouds,"
it's his, he's basically presenting the teaching
of Gautama Buddha.
It looks like you actually read that book.
I actually read it.
Look at that thing.
It's been beat to hell.
Either I read it or I carried it around a lot
and then would, like, take it out to impress people,
both might be true.
Just at the right moment at the right coffee shop.
Yeah, just like that.
Is that how you met April?
Yeah, I walked up to April and I said,
"Have you read this book by this Buddhist master?
It's pretty damn good."
So anyway, he's a giant obviously.
And one of those people that we should always revisit
when we're considering kind of our place in the world.
I think he's a great writer.
He lived in '95.
Beautiful man.
Beautiful dude.
And in that vein,
I wanted to also kinda recommend this book, Rebecca Pacheco,
who's a yoga and meditation instructor in the Boston area.
She was kinda like one of the,
she's a very popular instructor in Boston area
and she's written, this is her second book,
she wrote the first mostly about yoga,
and this one is about mindfulness and meditation.
And the reason I brought up Thich Nhat Hanh
is that Thich Nhat Hanh's,
I think his most lasting legacy is he introduced
the idea of mindfulness into our culture
here in the United States.
So everything else that
when you think about the idea of mindfulness,
the Jack Kornfield and all that,
that stems from Thich Nhat Hanh.
And then Rebecca Pacheco is kinda making that
really digestible and accessible for people.
I think particularly women will enjoy this book.
It's written from, with a very modern kind of,
even political kinda mind, but also a very understanding,
not political at all.
And I just think it's really well-wrought
and very accessible.
So if you're interested in getting into mindfulness,
you haven't, you don't know much about it,
I mean, this is a great first step.
And I just wanted to recognize her, so congrats to Rebecca.
Yeah, and that book just came out not too long ago.
Nice.
Adam.
Yes.
Survival is insufficient.
I know where you're going with this.
My next--
I remember damage.
Yes, there's some good ones in there, right?
What are the other ones?
I don't know, it's so highlighted.
I have it in here.
Oh yeah.
You highlighted it so that I can't even read it.
Here, I got it back.
I don't wanna live the wrong life then die.
To the monsters, we're the monsters.
Right, it's so good.
Of course, we're talking about "Station Eleven" on HBO Max.
This is the best thing I've seen on television
in quite a long time.
I recognized that I said that about White Lotus.
You did.
This is better than White,
I mean, it's different.
It's very different.
Let's just say they're different.
It's just an incredibly rapturous, beautiful miniseries.
I guess it will, are they gonna,
yeah, no, it's completed, right?
Yeah, there's no season two.
It's a one-and-done.
I think so.
Yeah, it's a one-and-done.
But they haven't gotten to 10 yet.
No, no, no, it's done.
It's based on a novel by Emily St. John Mandel,
that became a big deal, sold a lot of copies.
And it's this, for those that haven't seen
or don't know anything about it,
"Station Eleven" is kind of this post-apocalyptic
pandemic story that actually they started filming
before the pandemic.
Did you know that?
Right, yes, I did.
The book's five years old, right, six years old?
They had to take a break for like a year and a half
and then they revisited it.
But the inception of the story
was birth before everything that we're living through.
And the kind of weathering the pandemic aspect of it
is only a very tiny aspect of what the story really is,
which is this narrative that follows a group of people
and they're intersecting, time-shifting multinarratives
as they strive to survive and find meaning and connection
through the lens of trauma, of community, of art,
and Shakespeare.
And it's just, it's wonderfully wrought.
The writing is extraordinary.
It's elegant and it's visually stunning.
It was created by--
Very spooky.
Adapted and created by this guy, Patrick Somerville,
who is sort of a Damon Lindelof protege.
He worked on "Leftovers."
He created that show "Maniac" with Jonah Hill.
And some, not all, some of the episodes
are directed by Hiro Murai,
who was a director on that show "Atlanta."
Also Jeremy Podeswa, who's like just a legend
in television direction.
And the cast is insane.
Mackenzie Davis from "Halt and Catch Fire,"
Himesh Patel from "Yesterday,"
Gael Garcia Bernal, who is just wonderful,
Daniel Zovatto, who plays The Prophet.
I mean, it goes on and on and on.
But like, it's hard to encapsulate
or explain what this show is about,
but I just found it utterly captivating.
Yeah, I agree with you.
I've watched five episodes so far.
It's arty and dreamy.
And I love the fact that it's nonlinear,
and it's nonlinear in so many, in a lot of ways,
but specifically in time.
So you're hopping back and forth from 20 years ago
to 20 years forward to two years after the pandemic,
all the way around all the time.
So the creativity involved in that storytelling, I think,
is really interesting and makes it original.
I mean, it's as original as a nonlinear type story, I think,
that I've ever seen.
Would you agree?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Some of that storytelling technique
is kind of a Damon Lindelof type device
that first showed its hand in "Lost,"
kind of owes its legacy to that type of storytelling,
I suppose, on some level.
Right.
But this is even more jarring than that, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the costumes and the way that these storylines
ultimately end up intersecting with each other and--
The score.
The way in which
people are trying to make sense
of their world and they're going back to these texts,
whether it's that graphic novel "Station Eleven"
or whether it's Shakespeare,
and these routines like the traveling theater company
that goes in that same circle every year and never varies,
and the way that they are able to cultivate community
and try to find meaning through these artistic expressions,
like, it's just, I don't know.
To me, it's just brimming with beautiful creativity
and this idea that we play out,
like we're all in our, we're all in our story loops, right?
Like, they're traveling around Lake Michigan
with this thing.
Or we have this narrative that we tell ourselves
about why we are the way that we are,
whether that's rooted in trauma or routine.
And it's a story about like, ultimately,
trying to break free from those loops
and expand our life experience in scary new ways.
And I don't know, I mean,
there's a lot there, I think.
It's a perceptual experience, as much as anything.
Say it again.
A perceptual experience.
Like it's just, it's like, it's a sensory,
it's a very kind of like sensory experience.
It puts you into a different state of mind and body.
It's like a theta state.
It's like, you know how like some films
you're just watching and some, and reacting to
and you know you're on the couch watching it,
this is like a state of being.
It just puts your brain into a different state,
a different, yeah.
Yeah, and refreshing,
like it is this post-apocalyptic dystopian tale,
but what you, what that genre generally does
is show you this kind of like dark palette
and everything's gloom and doom and it's horrible.
But here we have nature emerging from the cracks
and we have levity and we have pettiness
and we have all of the complexity of human emotions
that are taking place under very difficult,
highly pressurized situations.
And there's something, like, really unique about that.
Yeah, I agree.
Anyway.
Some great performances.
Wait 'till you get to the finale.
I'll call you.
You're gonna cry.
Just great performances all around.
And I think you mentioned a bunch.
Matilda Lawler, the young Kirsten,
Danielle Deadwyler, Miranda Carroll,
and David Wilmot, Clark.
Unbelievable.
He plays Clark.
Just amazing.
The "Station Eleven" text itself is, it just stays with me.
There are some line--
Not the novel, you mean the graphic novel that's--
The graphic novel.
The text in the show.
Yeah, like the idea of escape.
You're never more yourself than when you're escaping,
which I think is a theme in this as well.
And I feel that way.
I mean, you just had an experience of that.
When I was mostly doing Lonely Planet jobs,
I mean, I loved being out there kind of on the walk about.
I definitely felt more permission to kinda be
who I really am.
And so I understand that idea.
And I think it's a really cool idea
'cause you could take that and infuse your life with it.
And so there's a lot in here that resonates with me.
I think it's a beautiful work.
I think it's haunting as well.
It's not just positive, it's haunting.
You're talking to a guy who watch "Contagion"
with his wife and like, in like week two of the pandemic.
Oh, I did that.
(Adam laughs)
That was like, wow.
How prescient was this movie.
Yeah, I watched "Contagion"
like the day after being at Whole Foods--
It's trauma bonding.
Where the shelves were bare.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It is trauma bonding.
We're trauma bonding.
The one thing that April doesn't get into,
and it's a good question,
is why everyone just like always going back to Shakespeare?
Shakespeare's had a big year.
Shakespeare's always,
every year is a good year for Shakespeare.
I know, but this year, in particular, the Coen movie
with Denzel Washington--
Right, right, that's true, "Macbeth."
Where else did Shakespeare crop up?
Just almost everywhere all the time.
Like Shakespeare has, like I mean, I get it, it's nice.
I mean, succession is very Shakespearean.
Well, I mean, Shakespeare told every story.
But did he?
Did Shakespeare even exist?
Did they?
Was Shakespeare--
Are we gonna go down the rabbit hole
of Shakespeare conspiracy authorship theories?
You know how I've, listeners,
I've been trying to push Rich into a spin-off podcast.
We just found it.
It's the Shakespeare committee.
We're gonna get into deep rabbit hole on the--
How heterodox of you.
The actual writers of Shakespeare.
All right, enough of that.
Let's move on.
Let's do some listener questions.
Let's do it.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the PlantPower Meal Planner,
are affordable, all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious, and easy-to-prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
And you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, people,
for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Rich?
Yes.
Before we get into listener questions,
I've got a title for our Shakespeare podcast.
What?
The Shakespiracy
So I guarantee you, there's a podcast called that already.
Shout out Jason Camiolo on that.
Now that's great writing.
From the people that brought you "Cowspiracy."
Wait, that's it.
Shakespiracy
They probably already own that.
Yeah.
Wait, you know those guys.
Yeah, I do know those guys.
We could get this, the Shakespiracy.
Why does everyone--
Cowspiracy, Seaspiracy, Shakespiracy.
There's a reason you're watching,
you're having, forced to read "Romeo and Juliet,"
"Macbeth" in class.
And it's not because they're great plays,
it's because of white supremacy.
Yeah, George Soros
has some role behind the scenes, I'm sure.
George Soros.
Who is George Soros, if not a secret Shakespiracy--
Shakespiracist.
(Adam laughs)
All right.
Let's go.
Hi, Adam.
This is Rebecca Jacob.
I am from Santa Maria, California.
And my question to you and Rich is this,
I am a 56-year-old woman
who is just recently been getting back into weight training.
I've always been active.
I follow a plant strong diet
and I've always also been a runner,
but recently was diagnosed with a degenerative disc disease
of which running kind of aggravates that.
I'm starting physical therapy today.
So maybe I'll have some exercises that they'll give me.
But so my question is twofold.
One, if I cannot get back to running,
can I still get zone-two workout
by doing non-impact type of movements?
And if so, what does that look like?
Rebecca, I feel you.
I'm sort of in the same place.
Been getting back into weight training
for the first time in a while.
My back is acting up, so I'm unable to run at the moment
without aggravating that.
However, the good news is,
yes, not only is it possible to get zone-two work in,
there is an even better way to do that,
better than running, which is cycling.
So I don't know if you have a bike
or you have an indoor bike or an indoor trainer
or access to a gym where you can get an indoor trainer.
But cycling is actually perfect for zone-two training.
Because unlike running, cycling is like this machine
where you can perfectly calibrate it for a certain level
of energy output so that you can specifically train
your aerobic base, your zone-two,
and stay in that zone for a much longer period of time
than you could running.
Because when you're running,
you're holding your body upright,
you can ride your bike longer than you can run,
and so it's actually a more optimal way
to train your zone-two than any other sport, in my opinion.
Now you tell me.
So my suggestion is to get into the bike
in whichever way works with your schedule.
Typically, I don't know how deep into
kind of the zone-two training world that you're in,
whether you've had lactate testing
or how you've established your zone-two.
But in general, the kind of thumbnail, imperfect thumbnail,
is whatever your range, your heart rate range for zone-two
on the run is, drop it about 10 beats for the bike.
So for me, my zone-two running is in the kind of 145 area,
like 135 to 145.
So on the bike, my zone-two is 120 to 130.
There are ways of dialing that in
more exactly through testing.
So my zone-two is not your zone-two.
That heart rate number should be meaningless to you.
Figure out what your zone-two is for the bike.
If you've done that work on the run,
drop it 10 beats, like I said.
I think the minimum effective dose
is something like 45 minutes 3 days a week.
But if you've been running and have some experience there,
you can expand on that as well.
So that's what I would do if I were you
and that's what I am doing, as a matter of fact.
I've been spending a lot of time on the bike
doing the zone-two work.
So for me, that's what it would look like.
But I would also suggest that, with your physical trainer,
that you start working on functional strength,
some chiropractic,
maybe some dynamic neuromuscular stabilization, DNS,
which has proved helpful
to kind of creating that functional strength
to stabilize your back.
I'm not saying that you can reverse your condition
or heal it.
But to the extent that which you can stabilize your spine,
through exercising these specific stabilizing muscles,
it will put you in a better place
to do these other activities
without creating further damage or unnecessary pain.
And I say that as not a, I'm not a doctor,
I'm not a physical therapist, I'm not any of those people.
That's just my experience
and maybe some things for you to look into.
But consult with the professionals
that you're consulting with.
Perfect, excellent.
I know you didn't ask me that question.
Why would you?
What question?
All right, here we go.
Sam from Baton Rouge.
Hey, Adam and Rich, my name is Sam Brian
from Baton Rouge, Louisiana.
My question is, I just listened to the episode,
the Prophets Walk Among Us,
where you had all of the listener call-ins
to give their own stories,
and you actually played mine, which is pretty cool.
My question is, though,
everyone who spoke kinda cited you as their inspiration,
their go-to podcast to turn to in times of strife.
And I think we all kind of have these pillars of inspiration
that we lean on.
And you are definitely that for a lot of people.
And I wonder if you have that type of hero?
This question is for both of you.
Is there someone that you just always turn to
when you're feeling down?
Who's your inspiration?
Who are your heroes?
Sam, you're gonna be really disappointed with answer.
I don't have, I get asked this a lot
and I really don't have a good answer to this question.
It's not like I can rattle off a list of people,
this person, that person.
I don't spend a lot of time
thinking about this kind of thing.
I look at it more not like as heroes
or people who inspire me,
but more like who are the people that are accessible to me
who can provide me guidance, wisdom, goalpost
on things that I'm struggling with?
And those are just regular people that are in my life.
I would add to that guests that I've had on the podcast,
like I'll reflect back on a conversation
that I've had with somebody.
'Cause the people that come on the show
are people that I wanna learn from,
perhaps I'm going through something
and I bring on this expert and they help me
kind of process in real time how to solve a certain problem
or think about a certain situation.
And some of those people had become friends,
so I can call upon them when I'm in need.
But I would say, more often than not,
like the people that inspire me
are like regular people that I have in my life,
like anonymous people.
Like, I'm going through a particular,
I'm trying to make a decision about a certain thing.
So I have a friend who's really good
at that kind of decision-making
and that's the person that I call.
Or I'm having a relationship thing,
or I'm having a professional thing,
or I'm having a sobriety thing.
Like, I have buckets with different people
for all of those different kind of aspects of life
that we all come across.
So I don't think, I'm like,
"Oh, that person that I put up on a pedestal."
I mean, one thing I've learned
in doing this for so many years is people are people, man.
Like, I've had some pretty fancy people come
and sit across from me on this podcast,
and that's always exciting--
Thank you.
And I get nervous.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
You're not one of those people.
Of course you are.
You don't have to say that.
And then you spend a couple of hours with them
and you're like, "Oh, it's just a guy.
Oh, just a," whatever.
And then you're like, "Well, if that's just a guy,
then that other person that I'm thinking about
in this really spectacular way,
well, they're just a human being too," right?
It really helps round you in that realization.
So that sort of cured me of a lot of hero worship.
So I draw my inspiration from all places.
And I think, for me, the most inspiring people
are kind of the anonymous heroes
who are doing amazing things
and not seeking attention for it.
Thank you.
There you are again.
You keep cropping up.
(Adam laughs)
You're everywhere.
I know.
You're like termites, crawling out of the wood.
I'm not asking for this adulation.
How badly do you want it, Adam?
How should I deliver the adulation to you?
Would you like it on a silver platter or on a gold bar?
I'll just eat it like a bowl of soup.
I can do that for you.
Like a Shakespearean era stew.
Back to the Shakespeare.
So I don't know.
Like I said, probably a very unsatisfactory answer for Sam.
But that's the truth.
That's a great answer.
I think that's totally real.
I, too, do not have a one particular hero that I look to
in times of strife.
But I do consult with Tao Te Ching on a regular basis,
if not at daily basis.
I have a yoga practice I try to do almost, I do daily,
lately it's been daily again, which is great,
and then I read a verse from Tao Te Ching,
which I've said on this podcast before,
and I contemplate it, I could be on one verse for 12 days,
I could be on one verse for a day.
So it just depends on my moment
and what's happening in my life
and that kinda keeps me oriented.
But another thing that I think about a lot is the Stoics,
because I get "The Daily Stoic" on my Instagram feed.
And it's not like I, I've never even read the book,
that's a huge hit by the way, Ryan Holiday's book.
But the idea of stoicism is something that I've,
I completely dovetail with and like
and the idea that you're here,
you're not here to have everything, the easy, or enjoyable.
And that wisdom from another age
is kind of my answer to that.
If it's the Tao, if it's "Daily Stoic" or whatever it is.
Because unlike you, I'm fortunate enough to be able to,
for my job, interview people who've done amazing things
and they are amazing human beings
and I do think about what I've learned from them as well.
And it's nice to have advice from friends.
But for me, like, that's what keeps me oriented.
If we're gonna expand this response to institutions
and literature, yeah, I would agree with that.
Marcus Aurelius, Epictetus,
Alcoholics Anonymous, the Group Conscience.
Bill Shakespeare.
Back to Shakespeare.
Yes, let your need for inspiration and wisdom
lead you where it may.
Bob Marley.
There you go.
All right, let's do the last question and tie this thing up.
Let's wrap a bow on it.
I thought we were gonna get under two hours,
but I don't think so.
No.
I'm too wordy.
All right, so the last one,
I'll play it on my phone for you, then we'll download it.
It's someone that you may have heard of.
Hey, Rich.
Hi, Adam.
I'm calling just because I've been feeling
like in a bit of a slump lately when it comes to running.
In the last week or so, I just haven't felt motivated
or even like enjoyed running.
To give you some context, I have been training
for the last six months, five days a week
and I run two half marathons and really enjoyed running
up until, like the last week.
So I wanted to ask what you would recommend
to help overcome it.
Is it like taking some time off
or is it pushing through it
and just hoping I end up liking it again?
I wanna continue running
to maintain the fitness that I've gained,
but I just haven't been keen to get into it lately.
Anyway, we'd love to hear your thoughts.
Thanks.
Oh yeah, that was April W. from Santa Monica.
As in April Wong, your wife?
Oh right.
This is your wife calling you.
(Adam laughs)
Were there no other voicemails on the service?
You're like--
There were.
She wanted in, so I gave him, come on, guys.
Come on, listeners, you got to indulge me on this one.
Let me make this easy for April.
April, you're feeling like you're in a bit of a slump?
That has to be because of Adam.
This is your fault.
It's clearly, clearly.
What are you doing to contribute to April's slump?
It's what I'm not doing, Rich.
Clearly.
You're the issue here.
It has nothing to do with running.
Are you showing up as a husband?
Let's make this about you.
Wait, wait, what?
(both laugh)
Listen, April, thank you for your question.
You've been running for six months, five days a week,
of course you're feeling like maybe
less than enthusiastic about it.
These things have to have a season.
Take a break, first of all,
before you make any drastic decisions
about your future as a runner.
Every athlete needs breaks.
So if you're worried about losing
the fitness that you gained,
let's try to do something else,
movement-oriented for a couple of weeks
and allow your body to kind of reset.
I mean, going six months, five days a week of running,
that's gonna give any runner a sort of malaise over it.
So I think that's number one.
The second thing is you don't have to be a runner.
Like, you're not a professional runner.
So if it's not doing it for you anymore,
you can feel free to switch it up
and find something else that you enjoy doing.
But before you do that, take that break
and then return to running
and maybe put something on the calendar,
find something within running that scares you or excites you
and set yourself up for a bit of an adventure
and that might inject your running experience
with a little bit more excitement and enthusiasm.
'Cause it sounds like you're just kinda doing it
to do it now.
You achieve these goals of running two half marathons,
congratulations, by the way.
Very quickly, too.
So is there another race,
like what's the backstory here, Adam?
Like, is there another race on the calendar?
What else is, first of all, you have a baby too.
So there's a lot going on.
Yeah, he's a toddler now.
She's done amazing.
She's like in incredible shape.
She ran the Malibu half in under 1:50.
She just ran another sub-two hour.
We had the Pasadena marathon, half marathon
and then the Ventura half marathon on the calendar,
but with omicron and just being with a toddler at home,
we are just not equipped to like going into the public
and breathing on each other quite yet.
So we didn't do Pasedena,
and she's not sure she's gonna do Ventura.
But she did it the same day.
She did her own course.
I had, like you, had a back injury, so I had to back out.
But we were gonna do, she was gonna be my partner
in the Otillo Catalina race, but that just got postponed.
So that was the plan, is do this half marathon
and then start getting in the water with me
and doing trails with me and doing Otilla,
but that just got postponed again.
So that's the backstory.
Yeah, okay.
So yeah, find something, take a break,
let yourself breathe, maintain your fitness in another way,
come back to it with something to put on the calendar
that would get you excited, that would be fun.
It doesn't have to be, even a race,
it could just be some kind of adventure
that you create for yourself.
And also, maybe try to make it communal,
like join a run club or meet some new people
to go running with or mix it up.
Go run someplace that you haven't run before,
like, I would make that suggestion
'cause you want it to be fun.
But the flip side of that is, like, you were,
we were talking about this earlier,
you're like, "I don't run 'cause it's fun.
Like, I run 'cause it's hard
and, like, I just do this thing," right?
It doesn't have to be fun.
You just do it and you push through these temporary phases
and these phases shift and change.
But I think the fact that,
April, you've been doing it for six months without a break,
like you're due for a break,
take that break and do it guilt-free.
Beautiful, I love it.
But April is a person who's like the type
that has like a favorite thing
and then she could just go off it, like,
which is amazing that I've stuck around,
that she's allowed me to stay.
Like, I hope that--
Like, she's a test case in David Epstein's book range,
just like, "I'm trying new things," good.
But also because she's--
You don't have to be a lifelong runner.
Like she's so good at like almost everything she picks up.
So that's also the other thing.
Yeah, I think when people are that,
have that kind of aptitude for almost anything,
that probably happens, I would say.
Must be nice.
Yeah, must be nice.
(both laugh)
All right, I think we did it.
We did it, man.
How do you feel?
I feel good.
I feel, I don't really wanna complain
about the inconveniences of modern life, so I won't.
Please don't.
Nobody wants to,
nobody tunes in here.
You indulgent Westsider.
Right.
I don't wanna get into what it's like for me
when like my nest heater goes up too high
without me knowing how to, have you ever figured that,
have you, do you have a nest?
Listen, Adam, suffering is suffering.
No, I don't have a nest, no.
The nest is winning.
Let's say I'm in a battle and the nest is winning.
Maybe you should a pitch a tent in the backyard
and you could be another just entitled rich Westsider dude
sleeping in a tent.
And The Young Turks can make fun of you.
As appealing as that role sounds,
I'm gonna pass on that.
No nest in the tents.
It's nest-free nest.
You know what would be interesting
is if your tent was shaped as a nest.
We can't really end this podcast on that note, can we?
(Adam laughs)
No.
I think that was a misfire idea, but I love you.
I love you, too.
And we're done, okay?
All right.
I just wanna say that I think it's great to have you back.
It's great to be back.
Happy to be back.
I feel like I'm getting my mojo back back in the saddle.
Missed all of you guys.
And again, this was the longest that I've gone
without doing a podcast.
And right now, I'm feeling grateful
and remembering how much I miss doing it,
and I still love doing it,
which is the whole reason for going away
to maintain this love affair with this medium
and doing this thing.
So thanks for taking this journey with me.
Thanks for having me.
Right on, buddy.
We'll be back in a couple of weeks.
Until then, you can follow Adam
on the socials @adamSkolnick.
I'm @richroll.
If you want your question answered for the show,
you can leave us a voicemail at 424-235-4626.
And don't forget to hit that subscribe button on YouTube,
Apple, Spotify, wherever you listen to the show.
I wanna thank everybody who helped put on the show today.
Jason Camiolo for audio engineering production, show notes,
and interstitial music,
Blake Curtis and Dan Drake
for the video version of the podcast,
Daniel Solis for graphics,
AJ (mumbles) for TikToks,
and also Dave Greenberg for portraits,
Georgia Whaley for copywriting,
DK for advertiser relationships and theme music,
as always, by Tyler, Trapper, and Harry.
Thanks, I love you guys.
See you back here in a couple days
with another amazing episode.
Until then, Adam, peace.
Plants.
To be or not to be.
Namaste.
(enlightening music)